Well, so a lot of my books are actually multiple books combined into one, right?
So, for example, Cryptonomicon is a
World War 2 book and a modern-day book
that are interleaved. And that's true of
a bunch of my books. So this one is a
high fantasy novel that's embedded in a
techno thriller. And the techno thriller
is about a guy who dies. And it turns out
that when he was a younger guy, he came
into a bunch of money. Was that my beard hitting the the mic?
Sometimes that happens. When he was a
younger guy and he came into money for
the first time, he signed one of these wills that gives instructions on
how to preserve his body after he dies.
So he'd be brought back to life. And
then he forgot about it. Because he
didn't really care; it was just sort of a
thing he did on a whim. But then he dies
unexpectedly and his family and friends
find this will sitting there like a time
bomb. And they have to figure out how to
carry out the terms of the will. And
because the deceased is a
billionaire, they can't claim that
there's a lack of resources, you know?
So he gets scanned. The way they do
it is they scan his brain and then later
on he is brought back to life in the
cloud as a digital simulation of a
consciousness. And there's nothing there. And he wants qualia; he wants something
to be there. I've just made Alvin very
happy by working in his favorite word.
Your brain is hooked up in such a way that you know it needs
stimuli, it needs inputs. And he's not getting any of that.
So he has to create them. And he starts to build a world that he doesn't have clear
coherent memories of where he came from. Just fragmented, jumbled
memories. And so he begins to try to
assemble a coherent world out of that
and ends up building a world that's kind
of like our world, but it's sort of a
mash-up of our world with, you know, the
Bible and Greek myths and Lord of the
Rings and, you know, whatever was going
through his head. And then other people
start showing up and sort of spreading
out and populating this world. And that
is the world in which the high
fantasy novel takes place. And we know
that it's a digital simulation, but the
people who live there don't know that.
It's as real to them as this world is to
everyone here, raising the question of: is
it just turtles all the way down?